Good morning, everyone. Welcome to this early morning
education session on the next generation of
conjugates. My name is Zhiqing Wang, and it's my pleasure to chair today's
session. As you can see, we have an outstanding lineup of speakers from both
academia and industry, so I look forward to the presentations and
discussions. Just trying to
hit a few housekeeping items. So we each try to
do a presentation for about 25 minutes.
There will be a Q&A session follows.
So there will be three microphones in the aisle, so just go up to the microphone,
and we'll prompt you for the question.
We'll probably take turns between different microphones.
So just trying to set the stage.
While the remarkable progress in ADC development requires
optimization of all different parts of the molecules.
So today we'll be focusing on payload.
This was an excellent analysis provided by Dr.
Raphael Colombo at last year's AACR, and he will update on
this at tomorrow's plenary. As you can see here, despite the explosive
growth of ADCs going to the clinic,
the payload diversity, as can be seen by those different color schemes here, are
very limited, still restricted to a few well-known
payload classes, such as MTI or topoisomerase inhibitors.
So now with clinical resistance emerging, there's really a strong need to expand
our payload toolboxes.
So with that, I'm going to turn over to Dr.
Toomey to the podium for the first presentation of the session.
Okay. Well, hello, everyone. So my name is Nathan Toomey.
I
am a professor at Binghamton University, and I've been
in the ADC field for going on
15, 18 years now. So
it's been fun to watch the development in this field.
And
my background includes both some time in the pharmaceutical industry as well as
in academia. And I moved into the academic space about nine years
ago. And when I moved there, one of my goals in
moving from
more pharmaceutical
industry-related research into academia was
to try to take ADCs outside of oncology and to use
some non-conventional payloads.
And so when I entered the field, one of my real
motivations and one of the things I focused on was immune-modulating payloads.
And so both immune-stimulating as well as immune-suppressing antibody drug
conjugates. And so that's the focus of my research lab here at Binghamton
University, and I'm going to talk about just some thoughts that I have around
immune-stimulating ADCs, and in particular, a program that I've developed in
my own lab. But I'll also talk about the field broadly and what I think are both
some promises and some pitfalls in it. So here's some disclosure information.
Of course, I am at Binghamton University.
I do work with a number of pharmaceutical companies and biotech companies as we
collaborate on various projects.
So the initiation of this project, of course, like
many of these types of efforts, began with the success of
checkpoint inhibitors that we're all aware of.
So checkpoint inhibitors, of course, we know are widely used,
but they have significant limitations in that very few patients respond
to them, but those that respond tend to respond very well.
And so one of our thoughts,
we along with many others, were thinking, okay, is it enough to just take the
brakes off of the immune system? Can we tap on the gas?
Carefully, of course, but tap on the gas.
And so that's kind of the advent of the idea of immune-stimulating ADCs.
And so the focal point of these has largely been on a
variety of innate immune receptors, so in particular toll-like
receptors, as well as STING. And
these innate immune receptors are involved in immune surveillance and
typically recognize
conserved components on bacterial and
viral pathogens. In particular, TLR3, 7, 8, 9,
and STING recognize various nucleotides, RNA,
DNA, and so on, whereas TLR1,
2, 4, 5, and 6 are typically recognizing lipopeptides associated
with bacterial cell
membranes.
So
TLRs,
the TLR7 in particular, where I'll be focusing, is an endosomal
receptor, and so it is
unlike many of the targets that we go after with traditional ADCs.
These TLRs are restricted. The expression is typically
restricted to immune cells and often to particular subsets of immune
cells. So TLR7 and 8, as you see here, has
expression in monocytes and B cells, whereas
TLR8 largely on monocytes and as well as
neutrophils.
STING has broad immune expression.
If you look at other TLR, TLR9 and TLR7 have very similar
expression profiles.
So the key point here is that
since the target of these payloads is in immune cells, okay, how exactly are we
getting the payload to these immune cells?
And the traditional approach is outlined here, where we
take a tumor-targeting antibody
with the TLR agonist attached to it, and this, of
course, opsonizes our
cancer cells, and then it gets taken up into tumor-associated
antigen-presenting cells via an
ADCP sort of mechanism that's driven by Fc gamma
receptors. And so typically, Fc gamma activity has
been required and is a key feature and is a key driving
factor with traditional immune-stimulating antibody conjugates or
ISACs.Upon internalization into the APC, of
course, the ADC gets degraded along with the tumor
cell itself, releasing the agonist and resulting in
the release of cytokines, cell proliferation, and T cell
stimulation, ultimately converting the idea, converting
a cold tumor to a hot tumor, essentially.
As you look at the key differences between traditional cytotoxic ADCs and
immune-stimulating ADCs, I think it's helpful to take a step back.
Some of these are things that I've learned the hard way.
But as you approach a program, there are key differences here, and in
particular, things that make the development of some of these immune-stimulated
ADCs approaches difficult are seen here in the lower left, and that where
they really differ from the development of traditional
cytotoxic ADCs. And so for in vitro assays, for example,
we can't do traditional cytotoxic assays.
We typically rely on co-culture assays to
advance compounds through triaging compounds and demonstrating
efficacy and so on in
an in vitro setting. In vivo models,
again, traditional ADCs rely on a xenograft sort of study with an
immunocompromised mouse. But of course, if we're going after the immune system,
trying to activate various immune pathways, that's not the best system to
demonstrate efficacy, although it does work, as I'll show you in a minute.
But syngeneic tumors are much more common, which of course introduces its
own complexities.
And often this ends up requiring a
surrogate antibody. And so the idea that rather than a human IgG
that we can typically dose into our
xenograft study, we have to go in with a mouse IgG that targets the
antigen of interest, which is of course problematic.
It adds some complexity to this. So that of course stems from ADA
concerns, which is a problem both in preclinical models and as we'll see, a
problem has been observed in the clinic as well.
But one of the things that's quite different, the types of toxicity that we
observe, very different. So we're typically looking at
CRS-related toxicities with immune-stimulating ADCs,
which has
some interesting possibilities that I'll finish this presentation with.
So there have been a number of these ISACs.
I'm going to call these first-generation ISACs that have gone into the clinic from
Bolt and Novartis, Silverback, Mersana, Takeda.
With the exception of the one from Mersana, these have dropped out of the
clinic
due to various reasons, many of the reasons associated with
cytokine release syndrome, as well as anti-drug
antibodies or ADA formation. Most of these, as you see here,
do employ non-cleavable linkers, and they employ Fc gamma
active ADC or antibody backbones.
This non-cleavable linker stems from the mechanism that I talked about earlier,
where the uptake involves Fc
gamma-mediated phagocytosis, so then you have
release of the payload right directly within the APC.
And so the non-cleavable linker actually helps it stay within the APC and not
diffuse into nearby tissues. That's been a mainstay of most of the
early-generation ISAC designs.
So
given that these first-generation designs have been
problematic,
what are some paths forward here? And these are my own thoughts here, and I know
not everybody's going to agree with these, but I think my own thought is
STING has some problems with it in that it has broad expression both in
tumor and non-tumor tissue. So getting, as we all know
in the ADC field, the amount of ADC that's actually delivered to the tumor
is really quite small. Most of it
actually ends up in non-tumor tissue.
And so the idea that STING is present in virtually all nucleated cells
in the body may be problematic from that perspective.
I think some of the experience from these early-generation ADCs point to the idea
that maybe we can
improve some safety through ablation of Fc gamma activity, and that's going to
require tweaking the linker, as I'll show you in a second here.
So if we can employ cleavable linkers and highly
permeable payloads, we can employ Fc silent
antibody delivery vehicles, as I'll get to in the next slide
here. And then TLR8, I think that given its high
expression and broad expression in
macrophages as opposed to TLR7, may present some problems
and may be behind some of the difficulties that Silverback faced with their
program.
I'm excited about some new pattern recognition receptors, TLR9,
TLR3, RIG-I, that are in earlier stage development.
TLR9 actually in the clinic, as I'll show you in a minute.
Okay, so the focus of my lab has been on TLR7
agonists. And so
one of the things I like about TLR7 is the fact that there's some
clinical validation associated with this target,
the TLR7 agonist imiquimod is
FDA approved for topical applications.
It does have systemic risk of CRS when dosed
systemically, hence the ADC or ISAC sort
of delivery approach.
It is clinically validated as a vaccine adjuvant.
It's used for basal cell carcinoma.
It has potent anti-tumor activity in various animal models, and it potently
induces the release of interferon alpha, which interferon alpha, of course, we
know has wide anti-tumor activity.
So together, I think the TLR7
agonists do have some strong validation
in terms of their use in ISAC approaches.
So our approach has been to take a twist off of
the Novartis Silverback Bolt approach, which relies on that
Fc gamma-mediated uptake, and instead rely on indirect
delivery of the TLR agonist to the tumor microenvironment through the use of a
highly permeable TLR7 agonist combined with a
cleavable linker. And so in other words, using classical
bystander activity to get into the tumor as opposed to
the indirect
ADCP-mediated
uptake.So the
agonist that we have employed, we
call E104. It's a twist on a
prior agonist that was purported in literature.
We tweaked it a little bit to allow for good
conjugation,
some selectivity, and in particular, permeability.
So this agonist,
it's a low nanomolar agonist against TLR7.
It has virtually no activity against TLR8.
It's active against both the human and the mouse TLR7 receptor,
and at low nanomolar levels, induces cytokine release in PBMC,
upregulation of CD80 and 86 on APCs,
has high permeability, as I mentioned, and it has rapid liver metabolism.
So in our mind, this is a good payload for
development of an ISIC approach. And so our design is
shown here.
The cases I'm going to show you over the next few slides,
I'll talk about both Trop-2 targeted as well as
HER2 targeted ADCs.
We link the E104
payload via a legumain cleavable linker.
The legumain cleavable linker is shown in yellow.
That's been something that my lab has focused on.
It's not the focal point of this discussion, but we've developed these legumain
cleavable linkers for ADCs, delivering a variety of payloads over the number of
years. But the thing I like about these legumain cleavable linkers,
two things. One is legumain
expression is upregulated in many solid tumors.
So you have very robust legumain activity in most solid
tumor tissues. And the
peptide that is relied on for cleavage, again, the one in yellow there,
is highly, highly polar. And so this kind of negates the need
for some of the fancier approaches with PEG and
phosphate groups and other tricks that people play in order
to improve the polarity of linkers.
The polarity is already baked into this linker. So we really like this.
We've gone in with largely DAR8 ADCs, which will have
some limitations, as we'll see. But anyway, this is our ADC design.
So I'll kind of walk you through a few things here.
Number one, this is in the context of HER2.
This is
some data from a paper we published last year.
So
we're going after SKBr3s, which are high HER2-expressing cells, and
looking for immune activation of co-cultured
murine macrophages, and we're looking for that via
both NF-kappa B as well as cytokine expression.
And again,
I just want to emphasize here that E104 itself has no impact on the
SKBr3 cells itself. So the payload has no toxicity, no
meaningful impact as far as we can observe on the
SKBr3 cells. What it's doing is it's releasing this payload to the
nearby APCs and activating those, and as you can see, we
see robust-- Whoops,
back up here. Robust activation of the NF-kappa B pathway in the
macrophages. Now, what I'm showing here is green versus blue.
Our green here is our traditional ISIC design, so this is
a non-cleavable linker with an Fc active antibody
backbone. The blue is our kind of
re-engineered or reimagined version of that, where we incorporate the cleavable
linker as well as Fc ablation. And so we see improved
specificity in terms of our targeted versus isotype control, so
very potent activity in terms of activating the tumor-associated macrophages.
But importantly, we have in a xenograft model here,
the HCC1954, we have improved efficacy, so it's a
matched dose. This is 10 MPK Q4d times three.
So you see the improved efficacy, but one additional thing I'm going to point out
here is the isotype control data right here.
So if we look at our traditional design that employs the Fc active
antibodies,
you see that the isotype control has some
meaningful tumor
growth delay here.
And we believe that this is driven by the Fc gamma
activity. So if we look at the gray line here, in our Fc ablated
ADC, we do not see any tumor regression at the same dose.
So,
this is also seen in
what I'm showing over here on the right, where we take these ADCs and we incubate
them in human PBMCs overnight. And what we're looking for is the release of various
cytokines. So I'm showing here TNF alpha and IL-6.
And what we see is in our traditional ISIC design in green, we
see a robust release of TNF alpha and IL-6. Again, no tumor here.
So this would have to be mediated by some
sort of nonspecific uptake, and I'm going to hypothesize that it's Fc
gamma-mediated uptake. So in our Fc silent version of this in
blue, we don't see any meaningful cytokine release.
We take this into a multi-dose study in an immune competent
mouse, taking blood samples, looking for
PK, but also looking for signs of efficacy.
And after our second dose, we see some significant toxicity,
perhaps ADA-mediated toxicities associated with our
traditional Fc
active ADCs, and this is just a few different permutations of this.
In a few different permutations of our Fc silent ADCs, we do not
see any meaningful activity there.
So we were encouraged by that.We take this
from HER2 and now applying this to Trop-2.
So exactly the same chemistry. Now we're going to apply this to a Trop-2 antibody,
so just sacituzumab. And what we're doing is taking CF PAC cells,
co-culturing those with human PBMC-derived
M2 macrophages, and we see a
nice expression of TNF alpha in the case of our Trop-2
targeted ADC here in red, our isotype targeted, and our naked
antibodies, we do not see the same cytokine release.
When we take these BXPC-3 cells, again, Trop-2
positive, co-culture those with bone marrow-derived macrophages,
M2 bone marrow-derived macrophages, you see, again, a nice IL-6 release.
Whereas in our case for isotype controls, naked antibodies, we do not see that.
And then finally, we did take this into a
xenograft model. I'm not going to show that result here just for the sake of time,
but I'll show you this
syngeneic model using Trop-2 expressing MC38 cells.
This is now in C57 mice, so again, immune competent mice.
We can see we can lower the dose dramatically.
So unlike the 10 MPK that was required for efficacy in the previous
study that I showed you, now in immune competent mouse, as you might expect, we
can see
efficacy at much lower doses at around 3 MPK and Q4D times three.
And encouragingly, once again, our isotype control and
naked antibody do not elicit any activity in this model.
So when we take blood samples from these
mice after-- If
I go back
here, we take blood samples basically four days after the last dose.
So here around day 12 or so, we're taking blood samples from these mice,
and what we're doing is we're doing an ELISA where we capture with
a immobilized Trop-2 protein, and then
doing our detection with an anti-mouse
Fc.
And so we're basically looking for mouse anti-human Trop-2 antibodies.
So that would be indicative of an adaptive immune response.
We can see four days after the last dose of Isaac, we see a nice
response. So we see a formation of mouse anti-human Trop-2 antibodies.
That persists for at least one month after that final
dose. Whereas when we look at just our naked
antibody treated control, we see a much lower or basically background
level response, same thing as PBS here.
Once again here in a repeat dose study in the C57 mice,
we're taking our Fc ablated Isaac versus our traditional Fc active Isaac,
and
we can tolerate up to 10 MPK. We actually didn't go any higher than this.
10 MPK for three doses. We don't see any meaningful activity on body
weight, movement, lethargy, that sort of thing.
We didn't do any sort of necroscopy here, but for what it's worth, in
life findings are very, very nice here.
Whereas, again, the traditional
design, even after the first dose at 3 MPK, we
start seeing some significant signs
in terms of
movement and lethargy and so on.
Okay. So, in terms of the payload, one
of the things that we want to see here is that the payload gets into our
tissues and gets out and then gets cleared very quickly.
And so we have not done PK on the payload itself yet, but I'm just comparing
here what Risiquimod looks like. So this is a very closely related
molecule,
and it gets cleared within
an hour or so. So it has very rapid
clearance. Our molecule has increased liver microsome
clearance as compared to Risiquimod.
So we believe it's going to have this rapid clearance similar to Risiquimod,
perhaps even more rapid clearance, which is kind of what we want to see.
Now, I will say that the ADC itself
is cleared more rapidly, and so I'm showing over here as compared to matched
dose of naked antibody versus our Isaac. Isaac is cleared more rapidly.
So we still have some room for optimization here.
These have been DAR8 ADCs, so we need to go in with a lower DAR, maybe some
site-specific conjugations, some things like that.
So
this is not a finished system yet, but we're working on it.
And then what I'm going to finish up with here is kind of where we're going next
with this. And I'm sure at this conference you'll see a number of dual payload
ADC talks. It's
kind of funny, I've been in the ADC field long enough that just
five,
eight years ago, people were scoffing and laughing at the idea of dual payload
ADCs. Now there's loads of people pursuing it.
Now, one of the things that I have always been concerned about when it comes to
dual payload ADCs is overlapping toxicities or synergistic
toxicities, because we know that many of the cytotoxic payloads out
there have similar
dose limiting toxicities that could exacerbate one another
if dosed together in the same molecule.
One of the things I particularly like about these immune stimulating
ADCs is that the types of toxicity observed are
completely
different than traditional cytotoxic ADCs.
Which means, of course, we're going to run into a dose limiting toxicity, but it
may not be synergistic. So
the toxicities will not necessarily be building on one another.
So the idea of a dual payload ADC that delivers
an immune stimulant and a cytotoxin, to me, is more appealing
than a dual payload that delivers two cytotoxins.
So our approach for this has been to
deliver MMAF along with E104. And the
reason for this is that MMAF is an
impermeable cytotoxin. And so our delivery mechanism, we're
delivering to, say,
HER2 or in this case, Trop-2 tumors.
So MMAFHas the anti-tumor activity within the cells delivered to, but
then our bystander activity being driven by the E104,
through the mechanism that I showed previously.
Now, our approach has been rather than branch linker, our approach has been
orthogonal conjugation using
the approach that I'm showing here, where one payload is attached via
transglutaminase chemistry using this thiolation chemistry that
we published on a number of years ago.
The other payload attached via traditional hinge cysteine, so
a basic eight plus two mechanism. And so given the
potency of MMAF, our thought was to go in with the
DAR2 for MMAF and the DAR8 for our
cytotoxin. But of course,
for less potent cytotoxins, we could kind of flip that.
So we did go through a whole battery of in vitro
validations that I'm not going to talk about here.
We'll be publishing this later this year, but I'm going to show you just some
results we got just a few weeks ago,
where we took this into a xenograft study.
And what I'm showing, I'm showing two different linkers.
I'm not going to say what those linkers are, but basically two different linkers
that connect E104. But I want to show you over here on the left,
this is three MPK Q4d times three.
Consistent with our prior efficacy studies,
our
prior efficacy studies required around 10 MPK before we saw efficacy.
So three MPK, the single payload ADCs didn't show
significant efficacy, which was not surprising in terms of
the prior results. So you can see the line there in blue is our
MMAF ADC single payload, no effect on tumor
growth. Red, our E104 ADC, no significant efficacy
on its own. But combined, you see in purple, we see significant
tumor growth delay. The ISIC control
in gray, you see no significant effect on tumor growth.
And then over on the right, we changed the linker a little bit.
In this case, our E104 ADC alone in
red did show activity on-- so single payload ADC did show activity, but
encouragingly, the combination in purple, dual payload ADC
showed improved activity as compared to the single.
By the way,
we didn't observe any sort of in-life findings in terms of weight
loss or behavioral changes, anything like that at those doses we were giving.
So we're encouraged by that. And then finally, what I want to say, what else is on
the horizon here? So there's a number of folks
that I'm encouraged to see that are kind of moving back into the ISIC
field. There's
a little bit of people moved away from it for a number of years, and that now a
number of folks are
trying to
look at various permutations of some of those original studies.
So we're seeing different
immune agonists. So
we see from
some TLR9 agonists now in the clinic, TLR9-based ISICs.
We see some more potent
TLR7 agonists coming from Bolt, going out against claudin 18.2.
A number of folks are taking cleavable linkers
and Fc ablated ADCs similar to our approach.
We see this from Daiichi Sankyo, Pfizer, and some from BMS.
I do understand the one from Pfizer perhaps has dropped down recently.
So I'm encouraged to see some folks getting back into this space, and I think it
has a lot of potential. Dual payload ADCs, Sutro has been one of the main
companies that has-- looking at immune agonist
plus a cytotoxin. They've been in on that for a number of years.
So I'm encouraged to see some people moving into that dual payload space.
So just in terms of some conclusions here, hopefully, I've shown you that we've
developed these ligamen cleavable TLR7 agonist-based ISICs
that exhibit some strong potency and some acceptable safety in these murine
cancer models.
Fc silenced ISICs induced reduced cytokine release, reduced off-target
uptake, hopefully leading to reduced CRS risk.
Of course, that has to be played out in the clinic.
And then dual payload ADCs, in particular tubulin inhibitors plus
TLR7 agonists show some promising activity really outperforming either of the
single payload comparators. So I'm encouraged to see where that goes.
And so this is my research team. I've got some amazing graduate students and
postdocs that have worked on this project as well as a bunch of other projects that
I have not talked about here. Funding has come from a variety of sources, both
in the private sector as well as public sector.
And I want to thank you for your attention.
So we open up for questions.
Frank Lee from WuXi AppTec. Yeah, great talk.
Thank you.
So one question I have, the co-culture PBMC
assay, like E104, your molecule was
anti-HER2 cleavable, like a stimulation is
quite different. So because
E104 gives very strong stimulation.
Why anti-HER2 cleavable
almost nothing from the data, right?
So what's the reason?
So I think you're referring to the PBMC culture that we did.
So this was
overnight incubation with PBMC, so there was no tumor antigen present, so there's
no real mechanism for the ADCs to get into the PBMCs.
That was kind of my point with doing that assay.
With the Fc ablation, there's no Fc gamma-mediated uptake,
so we really don't see any meaningful activation of PBMCs,
whereas in our Fc active comparator, we saw that Fc
gamma-mediated uptake, some activation cytokine release, which may be behind some
of the CRS that's observed in some of the clinical ISICs
to date.
Yeah. Thank you.
Ben Neal, NYU. Very nice talk. I have a question about your
Trop-2 engineered syngeneic model.
You said that you developed anti-Trop-2
antibodies as evidence of the adaptive response.
Do you also de-Develop a T cell response.
Did you try transferring the T cells or re-challenging with
the tumor?
We did not get to re-challenge. So, yeah, we should have.
Basically, our IACUC protocol was not approved for re-challenging.
So, no, we did not get to re-challenge.
Transfer the T cells.
Yes. We would like to
do that, though.
Over here.
Hi, I'm Hans Henning Böhm from Merck, Germany. I have a question.
Why did you choose MMAF, to
combine, instead of topoisomerase inhibitors?
A little bit against the trend maybe that we saw in the very first slide of the
session.
I think one of the reasons was,
MMAF was much more polar. So when we're talking about DAR eight
plus two, I was rather concerned about some of the
hydrophobicity that with some of the...
Of course, we could have engineered it
appropriately, but I think that just the conjugation would've been much more
challenging, if we used the topoisomerase inhibitors.
One of the other things that has concerned me a little bit is topoisomerase
inhibitors have been reported to up-regulate...
I'm sorry, TLR7 agonists have been reported to up-regulate
DNA repair pathways, and so that does concern me a little bit about the
combination of topoisomerase inhibitors with
TLR7 agonists as compared to, TLR7 agonists with
tubulin inhibitors.
Thanks.
Hi. Hello. I'm Zhipeng from Roche.
So I have question regarding the immunogenicity.
I think ISAC,
one of the potential liability is the strong
immunogenicity and ADA concerns.
For your
FC mutant and cleavable design and also the
dual payload design, do you think this will have
a reduced concern regarding immunogenicity?
That is certainly our hope, but I will say in our mouse models, we do see
strong immunogenicity. However, I think we see strong
immunogenicity even in control conjugates that do
not have our TLR7 agonist on board.
So
one of the things we're trying to do right now is to go in with surrogate
antibodies, so basically a mouse anti-human
Trop-2 version of the ISACs that we've shown and see if
those have immunogenicity. We have not done that experiment to date.
What about the cytotoxic dual payload?
We have not done the immunogenicity studies with our dual payload
ADCs. I would expect we do have it, but again, these are human
antibodies dosed in a mouse, so virtually any ADCU dose is going to
have that immunogenicity. So I don't think it's unique to the ISAC approach that
we're taking.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi, this is Hang Chen from Remgen. Wonderful talk. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I have a question about the TLR8 you mentioned is also
highly expressed in the neutrophil.
I know some people also want to engage a neutrophil to attack a
tumor. Can you explain a little bit more about why you don't want
neutrophil?
So I'm approaching this as more of a chemist than immunologist, but
I guess my thinking has been we want to be able
to activate the types of immune cells that are in the tumor
microenvironment and avoid as much stimulation as we can,
for non-relevant immune cells because, of course, those
just during systemic exposure, we could have just some off targets here.
We know CRS is a problem, so let's try to limit the exposure as much as we can to
the tumor-associated cell types.
That's simplistic thinking on my part, but yeah.
Okay. Last question.
Thank you. That was a great talk. Mark Orr from Astellas.
I was wondering if you could say a little bit more about how you're thinking on
the, choosing the DARs for these dual, immunostimulatory and
toxin ADCs. I think you said you had an eight plus two in the data you presented.
Sorry. The question is about how I think about the DAR ratio?
Yes. Selecting, optimizing the DARs for the dual payloads.
Okay. So in a way that's
fairly straightforward when you think about it because we have a good
idea of the efficacy and tolerability of the single payload ADCs.
So like in our case, we were going in
knowing that MMAF, there's a long history with MMAF, so we
know roughly what doses that we should see efficacy
at, and we know what doses we see efficacy for our single payload
TLR7 agonist ADCs. So
we know which one should be more and which one should be less.
So I like that eight plus two motif because we can just gear it
towards whichever one's the most potent, make that our DAR2.
That's simplistic thinking, but...
Okay. So with that, I'm going to turn it over to Shixiong Wang, who will give our
second presentation.
Sorry.
Okay. Thank you Dr. Mi for your excellent presentation and discussion.
So, again, my name is Shixiong Wang, and I'm going to switch gears, talk about our
work from my time at AbbVie, focusing on identifying kinase inhibitors, in this
case, PI3K/mTOR inhibitors as ADC payloads to target the
tumor intrinsic vulnerabilities.
So why PI3K? With the successful launch of ibrutinib and
venetoclax, we asked ourselves a question.
What are the targets we want to go after next to really enhance the clinical
efficacy and also address emerging resistance?
So this had to led us to PI3K.
As you can see here on the left diagram, which represents a B-cell signaling
pathway, so PI3K, especially PI3K delta, is
really a central node to really the B-cell activation signal downstream
leading to malignant cell proliferation.So this dependency
has been validated by the approval of multiple marketed drugs, shown on the left,
for the treatment of B-cell malignancies.
Preclinically, there's indication there significant potential
to combine PI3K inhibitors with those two agents.
There's also been suggested that the APEM PI3K profile will
be beneficial to treat diffuse large B-cell lymphoma,
which is a new indication.
So unfortunately for those PI3K inhibitors, their use are very
limited by severe on-target adverse events.
Some of them are shown here. So this very poor benefit to risk
profile
really limits their use and result in multiple market withdrawals, as can be
seen by those crossed out indications.
So that's the exact reason why we want to pivot into the ADC platform.
We
rationalize
by leveraging the tumor-specific mechanism, we can reduce,
enable rational combination, and also treat new indications.
So to be an ideal ADC payload, they will need exquisite level for
biochemical potencies. If you look at most of the market-approved
drugs, most of them really fall short.
Look at the omipalisib, which is the experimental drug as shown here.
It really has the exquisite level of potencies against the various isoforms
of PI3K. It's also quite active against mTOR, as shown
here, which to us could be advantageous, especially in the solid tumor
indications. Because mTOR is right downstream from PI3K, by
inhibiting both, we can suppress this adaptive resistance,
hence enhanced the durability.
So on the right is a
panel of lymphoma cell lines. As you can see,
the outstanding biochemical potency of omipalisib
translates into a really high sub-nanomolar to single-digit
nanomolar cell growth inhibition, really position this payload well for further
exploration.
So to
optimize omipalisib, there are two key goals.
The first one is to try to improve the potency even more, and the second is try to
build in a functional group for linker attachment without disrupting the binding.
So for the first goal, we utilized this fragment molecular orbital analysis
or FMO analysis. This is a quantum
mechanic-based method. So basically,
it's a calculation of the most important interactions
between the amino acid residues with a ligand and identify the
most important pairs. So each of the vertical bar represent a particular
amino acid residue. You want to look for the most net negative gain.
So as you can see here, lysine 833 holds great promise, and also
based on this green color, which represents the electrostatic interaction, that's
something we're going to go after.
So with that insight,
we added a single fluorine atom to the phenyl ring.
So reduce the effective pKa of this NH, lead to
stronger electrostatic or cell bridge interaction with the lysine
833.
Furthermore, we
have this terminal free amino group for linker attachment.
As you can see here, there's actually meaningful improvement of PI3K
activity,
as well as cellular activity. So the next thing we did is
try to improve the... Okay, so
going back just a little bit. So this compound one became our
payload for most of the HEM cell line characterization.
We further want to improve on the mTOR activity, so in this case, we replaced this
bis-cyclic ring with this tricyclic bidentate hinge binder.
So what this does is really enforce a pi-pi stack interaction with
mTOR tryptophan residue 2239. So we saw a significant
improvements of the mTOR activity, while not really sacrificing the
PI3K activity. We also see a concurrent
improvement
of the cellular potency.
So to identify the best antigen, we
look at the expression profiles of CD19, 22, and
70b across both tumor and also normal tissues
in different databases.
As you can see here, 19, 22, and 70b have very similar expression levels,
primarily in the B-cell malignancies or B-cell
lineage normal tissues. So we decide to go with the CD70b
because it's a clinically validated antigen by
association with the Polivi, which is a
MMA-based ADC.
So with CD70b selected and equipped with compound one, we prepare
two linker drugs. First one has this BRAC gly-lysine.
Another one has MA gly-Ala.
So as you can see here,
what we're trying to do is we're trying to maximize ADC potency, so we enable the
DAR 10 format.
Still though, if you look at the property, they're actually very good with very low
aggregation and
very high mouse plasma stability.
So when we look at the ADC data in the panel of
lymphoma cell lines, that's shown in green, those compounds are actually quite
potent,
sometimes overlapping with that of the blue curve, which is the free payload.
There's substantial separation between the targeted ADC versus isotype
ADC and the antibody.
So having established the high in vitro potency, we move those compounds
into a TMD lymphoma cell model. On the left,
this is a ibrutibib-resistant C481 mutant
line. As you can see here, twice dosing at the five and 15
MPK, we saw tumor regression outperforming either the antibody or
the isotype ADC. On the right, we perform the dose titration
study. As you can see at the dose as low as 1.5
MPK, we outperform the copalisib,
which was approved the drug at the 5 MPK.
This is a therapeutically relevant dose.
At higher doses, we saw pronounced dose-dependent tumor
regression.
If you try to back-calculate the tumor stasis dose, it turns out to be around 3
MPK, which is pretty impressive.So across these two different studies,
LD1 and LD2, these two different linker drugs performed almost
identically.
So the
utilization of a targeted therapy, as our payload, gave us this unique
opportunity in examining the tumor PK/PD relationship.
So in this case, we measured the phospho-S6 ribosome protein
suppression, which is the downstream marker for PI3K inhibition,
and correlated back with the tumor payload levels after the treatments
of the ADC.
You can see here, there almost seems to be a threshold effect.
Once the payload level is above about 100 to 110 nanogram per mil,
it's associated with a pretty robust phosphorylated S6 RP suppression,
indicating high target engagement.
On the right, we plotted the tumor growth inhibition versus the tumor
payload level in excess of the
IC50 of the payload. As you can see, when the ratio exceeds about one,
it's associated with a tumor growth inhibition of over 100%,
meaning tumor regression. So this data, in totality
really supports this
concentration-dependent efficacy, and it really establishes the
pharmacodynamic benchmarks for optimized
ADC activity.
So we moved our ADC into two other DLBCL models.
On the left, this is a so-called active B-cell lymphoma model.
It performed very similarly to TMDA.
We saw tumor regression at 15 NPK. On the right, this is the
LLY1 called the germ center B-cell lymphoma model.
Usually not very responsive to PI3K delta inhibitor, but because our payload
is a pan-PI3K inhibitor, you do see a dose-dependent
sensitivity, especially at 15 NPK.
So this just tells us our single agent can actually have broad-spectrum
activity across different DLBCL cell lines.
So building on the single-agent activity, we wanted to explore next,
the rationale biological combination.
So again, looking at this LLY1 model.
It turns out this LLY1 is a specific presentation, a
so-called the double-hit lymphoma,
because it has a translocation of c-MYC and the BCL2.
So in the clinic, this is a very aggressive form and high-risk
form of lymphoma. Sometimes it's actually not very
responsive to chemo such as R-CHOP, but it really provides a
perfect biological rationale for us to combine our PI3K ADC
with a BCL2 agent such as venetoclax.
So in this case, we use compound two as our payload because it's higher
potency. As you can see in the graph on the lower left, the green
line represents the combination of our PI3K ADC with the
venetoclax. You saw pretty exceptional
tumor suppression and sustained efficacy, much better
than copanlisib or the ADC alone. Also much better than the
copanlisib plus venetoclax.
Well, notably, there's no weight
loss associated with any of the ADC group.
So this mechanism of action work on the right explains the
synergy. PI3K inhibition leads to
GSK-3beta activation, which will in turn
phosphorylate the MYC. And as you remember, this is a MYC
translocation
cell line.
Then when that's phosphorylated, that will lead to
proteasome-dependent degradation, and we definitely demonstrate that dependency.
So you can see there's a dose-responsive
MYC degradation concurrent with phospho-S6 RP suppression,
so meaning on-target effect.
So this data clearly demonstrates the potential combination potential
for our PI3K ADC with the venetoclax in this high-risk
patient population.
Just to summarize the first part, we have been able to identify
ADCs that demonstrate the tumor stasis dose in a sensitive
HIM model at about three NPK.
So this ADC is actually remarkably well-tolerated in rats up
to 150 NPK, in the monkey up to 100 NPK.
The target organs are very consistent with approved PI3K
inhibitors.
So with this substantial level of safety margin, we
asked a very logical question: Can we use the PI3K
BDCs for solid tumor indications, which have very large
unmet medical needs?
So to answer this question, I think this audience is very
familiar with that. The PI3K pathway is probably one of the most
disrupted pathways in human cancers, accounting for about over
40% of the patients altogether. Just the
PIK3CA, which is the PI3KA,
PI3K alpha mutation, drives about 13% of the
cases.
So there are many approved and also experimental agents, as highlighted here,
either in green or
in red. There probably will be many more agents coming.
So they target different nodes. There are PI3K inhibitors.
There are MTOR inhibitors. Of course, there are AKT inhibitors.
It's always going to be a balancing act between the efficacy
durability versus on-target toxicity.
So, as you can see, our payload targets really different nodes here.
So we're hoping we can really balancing out the efficacy, the
toxicity, but more importantly, to unlock the combination
potential.
So just the quick analysis of the
indication strategy. If you look at the PIK3CA
alteration landscape based on cBioPortal analysis on the left,
PIK3CA alteration primarily includes either amplification
or hotspot mutation. So those alterations dominate in
cancers such as breast, squamous lung, and head and neck.
So those should be the patients will be most sensitive to our
agent.There are also PI3K wild-type tumors, but PI3K
can still play a significant biological role.
For example, in the RAS mutant setting, PI3K can still play a
downstream effector molecule.
There are also PTEN loss and the aktor amplification patient population.
So if you combine those genetic backgrounds together, we can still constitute
a pretty
broad landscape where our single agent can be effective.
So of course, there's a huge combination potential because of the
robust scientific rationale. So there are many agents we can combine
PI3K ADC with, including
MEK inhibitor,
TKI, CDK, and estrogen receptor inhibitors.
So to maximize the potential in solid tumor, we want to optimize our
payload a little bit more. So in this case, we made a slide,
structure modification. We include this hydroxyl as the amide group.
So this hydroxyl is important to engage sort of a more
hydrogen bond network within mTOR to boost the potency by a
fewfold, and also having this free hydroxyl will enable us
to include a GGFG linker, as I will speak on
subsequent slide.
So this page on the left, basically just trying to put into
context how potent our compound has become based on both the
mTOR activity and also PI3K alpha activity.
It sits at the lower left corner versus some of the
approved agents here.
So in the kind of profiling study, our compound is actually quite selective,
especially against the non-lipid kinases.
It also maintained a fairly reasonable selectivity profile in a
separate panel screening of 78 targets.
So overall, this is a highly
optimized molecule.
So I can see this is old slide deck that hasn't been updated, but I'm just going to
blow through real quickly. So we look at this compound, just to
profile this compound versus some other comparators in this specific
T47D breast
cancer cell line.
Probably just to point your attention to the graph on the right.
This is a correlation of the cell growth inhibition versus
phosphorylation pathway suppression.
Again, compound three is orders of magnitude more potent than everything else.
And also there's a very nice linear correlation between those
two values, indicating a very specific target
pathway inhibition.
So I'm going to just go through this picture real quickly.
Of course, I just showed the data in a single cell line, but we really want to
understand the profile of this compound in the broad spectrum cell panel screening.
So we submit this compound for a DenMap screening.
So it turns out this compound, actually in terms of sensitivity profile,
is highly correlative to other known PI3K/mTOR
inhibitors. And also, if you look at the pan-cancer analysis on the right,
those cells that harbor PIK3CA mutation are extremely sensitive, as
represented by this lower numeric
AUC value. And that translates true for different lineages.
So overall, this really tells us our compound is highly on target.
Really no surprising off target identified.
So I think selecting the right antigen is really important.
So we selected HER2 as our antigen based
on both the genetic and also clinical
validation. Of course, HER2, who needs another HER2?
But I think we have strong rationale for that.
If you look at the codependency analysis, there's a high
codependency between PIK3CA versus HER2, which makes perfect sense because
PI3K is right underneath of HER2 pathway.
But also if you think of if this PI3K activation mutation, then
it can potentially to escape from HER2 therapy.
That turned out to be the case by this clinical study that was published 10 years
ago. If you look at the two right bars for the front line
HER2 therapy, in this case it's lapatinib plus
trastuzumab. The patients who actually have the
PI3K activation mutation responded much poorly
than the patients who are wild type.
So this
makes sense, right? Because HER2 is really upstream, but when you have a survival
pathway downstream, right? So that's going to escape.
But that also implies those tumors should be sensitive to PI3K
inhibitors. So that was proven to be true by this
preclinical study on the right. This is cell line that developed the
trastuzumab resistance. But when we add back PI3K
inhibitor or PI3K/mTOR inhibitor, you saw tumor regression.
So this really lead a pretty strong therapeutic rationale.
So for us, when we have a HER2 PI3K ADC, we're not just
using HER2 simply as the cell surface marker, but we actually target
those cells where PI3K activation can lead to escape.
So by combining these two synergistic most together,
we can
prevent escape and potentially address resistance and
really enhance efficacy.
So we enabled our
HER2 ADC by using the GGFG linker, because we
like the stability and its overall release specificity.
It's obviously one of the more validated linkers out there
in agents such as Enhertu. We looked at both pertuzumab and the
trastuzumab ADCs, and they actually performed very
similarly. And you will probably see data for both of those
antibodies.
But we decided to move forward with the pertuzumab ADC because the combination
potential with Enhertu and also trastuzumab.
So when we look at the cell potency of our ADCs in this
HCC1954 model, which is a HER2 high breast
cancer model, our ADC in purple is very
potent. It's actually more potent than the free payload.In this
ZR74-5-1 HER2 low model,
it has a PIK3CA null mutation, so it's still pretty sensitive to the PI3K
inhibitor, as you can see here. But this compound has a weaker,
but yet still pretty distinctive sensitivity to our ADC.
And if we plot the HER2 expression levels versus our
ADC sensitivity, there's a pretty nice correlation indicating
antigen-mediated effect.
So I want to quickly discuss about this bystander effect studies.
So in this case, it's a tissue co-culture study.
We mixed HER2-positive cells with HER2 negative cells, in this case,
HCC70 cells. So to better
monitor these HER2 negative cells, we gave a red
nuclear eye label so that we can monitor the
viability. In the meantime, we also had a green
fluorescence label on this FoxO3A protein, which is a AKT
substrate. So that will allow us to monitor the AKT pathway.
So when monitoring the
red object counts, which is an indication of the cell viability,
our HER2 ADC actually demonstrate pretty substantial bystander
effect as in HER2 in terms of the bystander cell
killing shown here on the left side of this page.
However, when we're looking at the green marker dynamics, they
behave very differently. So in HER2 had very little change, but
our PI3K ADC, we saw pretty substantial
inhibition of this phospho-AKT pathway.
So this tells us even though both kinds of agents lead to a
similar level of bystander killing, but the mechanism by which they're operating
are very different.
So moving our ADC into efficacy studies.
At 3 MPK, we saw tumor growth inhibition, but at
nine MPK, we saw tumor regression.
In the same model, alpelisib only led to stasis
and followed by tumor relapse once we stopped dosing, and
trodelvy was not active. It's worth noting that our ADC
groups had no body weight loss. However, alpelisib, we did
observe a body weight loss and the dose-limiting toxicity.
Looking at the PD markers, in this case, we looked at the phospho-AKT.
At nine MPK, all the way out to 240 hours, we
saw complete AKT suppression, while if you look at the systemic
agents, even though they were dosed once every day,
the suppression was not nearly as complete and seems to be a little bit transient.
In another HER2 high model, this time it's a slightly different PIK3CA
mutation.
Our pertuzumab ADC at 10 MPK showed tumor stasis comparable to in
HER2. So on the right, this is sort of a clinical modeling
experiment. So we treated the tumor first with alpelisib, we saw
stasis, then we took the alpelisib
off, then the tumor started relapsing.
At this point, we gave a rescue dose of our pertuzumab ADC.
We saw very rapid tumor regression to a lower baseline level.
Now, another HER2 low models. The first one on the
left is T47D model. As you can see, at the 15 MPK, our
ADC had pretty substantial tumor regression and tumor stasis.
Trastuzumab doesn't work, and trodelvy didn't work at all.
This is interesting because T47D is HER2 positive.
In this PDX model, we can see sort of a door-dependent tumor growth
inhibition.
So this data really demonstrates our ADC can actually be
efficacious even in a HER2 low setting.
Okay, this is a really early version, so I don't know why it was not updated.
But anyway, so I'm just going to point your attention to this particular
PI3K wild type in the non-breast cancer model.
So in this OE19 model with the trastuzumab ADC, at the 15
MPK, we saw tumor growth inhibition, while
trastuzumab and alpelisib both were not nearly as active.
Now going to combination studies shown below.
As you can see here with the sub-efficacious dose of trastuzumab and our
pertuzumab ADC really led to massive synergy.
On the right, this is a KRAS-dependent pancreatic cell line, which is
sensitive to G12C inhibitor. In this case, it's sotorasib.
You see some tumor growth inhibition.
And we also had the proof of concept PI3K ADC CD71,
because this cell is CD71 positive.
We did see some efficacy, but when you combine the two agents together in a green
curve, it led to tumor
regression. So combining all this data together clearly
validates the broad
utility of our platform and the powerful combination potential across
diverse genetic backgrounds.
So now going to transition to the safety studies.
Here we summarize the preclinical tolerability and the PK profile of our
ADC in rat.
If you look at this ADC, it's actually well-tolerated in rats at the 50
MPK. We look at exposure levels, and the total
antibody and the total ADC are virtually superimposable.
And that, coupled with the very low free payload release,
indicating this conjugate is actually very stable in the systemic
circulation. So the pathology findings are very
consistent with on-target effects.
So because of this combination of the tolerability
and also stability in rat, really derisks this platform from
off-target liabilities.
So now I just want to summarize. So we started from omipalisib and
went through multiple cycles and identified different
payload... for different sort of types of cancers
through this rationale iterative design.
We enhanced the pharmacology by including mTOR, and also we were
able to improve the pharmacological profile,
identify a linker attachment, hence enabling various
antibody drug conjugates that demonstrate the robust target engagement and
efficacy in both hematological and also solid tumor
models. These are actually well-tolerated and demonstrate the
tolerability in rat exposure and tox studies of up to
50 MPK. So this molecular design framework can definitely be
applied to other types of molecules for payload
development.
So I just want to wrap up. I want to really thank my coworkers at
AbbVie previously and currently for making this possible.
I'm incredibly grateful to their dedication.
And also I want to highlight the work of my coworker, Chi Lu, who's in the
audience. He was the chemistry lead for this program as of
recent. So he'll be presenting a poster with the title shown here.
There'll be much more SCR optimization and also
pharmacology characterization data in his poster, so
please come by, check it out if you're interested.
It's going to be in tomorrow's session.
So with that, I'm going to thank you for your time and attention.
I'd be happy to answer questions.
Yeah, thanks for the great talk, frankly, from Wish Abtech.
So I have a question for your TMT8 model, the Hema model,
right?
Because from your in vitro assay, like your
omilifib with bare
copalib,
more like only beta and gamma PI3K just
show improvement. But from that model, but
I expect the bare compound should show some efficacy because
you do have ADC naked antibody control on the
left, did not show any efficacy. So what's the reason?
Because
your kinase inhibition very similar.
But I think more like ADCC, ADCP
effect, plus your inhibitor effect.
But from your control, the antibody, that is not the case.
So what's the reason? Because only slightly different beta and
gamma inhibition cause huge difference.
So I guess your question is why the ADC shows much better efficacy than
anybody, and even though the PI3K
activity was not that much better?
Why bare compound no efficacy at all, basically that's fine.
Why copalib doesn't have efficacy at all?
Yeah, because your CD79a and with
your inhibitor show greater efficacy, right?
Yeah, I think copalib, obviously, I think the 5
MPK was an efficacious dose, but it's probably not the maximum efficacious
dose.
Okay.
So I think that allows us for the comparison, but I think another very
interesting mechanism rationale is what we did find, which I didn't show today, is
that PI3K inhibition can actually lead to CD79B upregulation.
So you have this sort of feed-forward mechanism, which can potentially make your
ADC more efficacious than if you were to combine the antibody with
the inhibitor alone itself, right?
So there's some sort of synergistic-
Mm-hmm
... effect between CD79B and the PI3K.
Okay, last question. Basically, so many B-cell target, why
CD79B, not A, not others?
We actually didn't make those conjugates.
CD79B was obviously validated because the polyB had shown a lot
of clinical effects.
We looked at some of the others, CD90 and 22, I believe,
didn't look as good as CD79B as well.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Hi. Thanks, Dr. Wang, for the nice talk. I'm Jipeng from Roche.
So I noticed you used two different
linker and payload design for liquid and solid tumors.
I'm just wondering whether you could briefly summarize
for different type of tumor, what's the preferred
linker and payload activities? And whether for your solid
tumor linker and payload, you tried that in the liquid
tumor as well? What about the
performance?
Okay, is the question if we use the solid tumor
payload in the HEM model?
So we do have a compound two actually showed--
we had data for compound two in both
HEM and also solid tumor cell lines.
So clearly solid, always you're going to see a right shift.
Mm-hmm.
Does that make sense? So I would imagine, I would say if we apply compound
three back into HEM, I would think probably it would perform better, but
we didn't do that experiment.
Okay. Yeah. Thank you.
Okay.
Hello, I'm from Zai Lab. Thank you for the very exciting
talk. So I have two questions. One is, now you have a large
molecule, right? So, do you worry about the tumor
penetration? And the second question is, compared to conventional
kinase inhibitor,
have you seen less tox with this conjugation?
Thank you.
Right. So I think the tumor
penetration wasn't a big issue,
because we did see the PD. In fact, we also saw pretty substantial
tumor payload. I mean, that's the exact reason why you want to use the antibody,
right? So I don't think that's necessary, is that barrier itself.
And also, our compounds
do have pretty substantial bystander effect.
Second question, do we see less tox?
I think it's a harder question to answer,
because you really have to be very quantitative about it.
But what I can say is the organ tox
profiles, or at least the organs, are
veryAlmost identical, right? But then it's really based on some of the
therapeutic exposure levels versus the efficacy exposure levels
to define that margin. Right.
Thank you.
Thanks for your talk. On the same topic of talks, did you see
hyperglycemia in any animal model?
We do not see that. Good question. All right.
I think we're going to wrap up this
part, and I would like to invite Dr.
Ito to the podium for the final presentation of this session.
Okay. Good morning, everyone. My name is Koichi Ito
from Prelude Therapeutics.
I'm from Biology and Pharmacology Group, the Prelude.
I'm going to talk about today
our new ADC approach with targeted
protein degrader or TPD molecules as a payload.
We sometimes call it the degrader antibody conjugate or
DAC.
Here is my disclosure information.
And, yeah, we
learned about
the two really innovative new
payload approach for ADC. Perhaps we are all trying
to improve or modify the
traditional ADCs with cytotoxic
chemotherapies,
which successfully have proven that this modality,
antibody drug conjugation modality, actually works in patients.
But we also learned a lot
from these traditional ADCs
about how to use it safely and more effectively,
and also where further
improvements are needed.
So at the Prelude, we are really focused on
using a targeted protein degrader or TPD molecule
as a payload in instead of the cytotoxic chemotherapy.
Unlike this conventional cytotoxic
chemotherapy agent,
targeted protein degrader or TPD molecules can
really selectively degrade your target protein
with a well biologically validated
function. So you can modulate the specific
oncogenic pathways by using TPD. So
with these two layers of selectivities, antibodies,
and TPD molecules, we hypothesized that
this DAC approach, degrader antibody conjugate approach,
have a really strong potential to deliver
both improved efficacy and improved
tolerability.
And also in terms of the PD marker,
because we are degrading your target protein, it is
relatively straightforward to track the PD in cells and the
patient, unlike traditional ADCs.
And also, TPDs
are typically non-genotoxic, which is important for
develop-ability because we are not directly targeting DNA.
So,
just for
some of the audience who may
not be so familiar with this targeted protein degrader approach,
let me just briefly introduce this concept.
The TPD molecules are typically
heterobifunctional
molecules, are composed of the ligand of protein of
interest, E3 ligase,
connected via a linker.
There are monovalent degraders or molecular glues, but I'm not going
to talk about those molecules today.
And these TPD molecules themselves have a really strong
potential to be a novel therapeutic approach or
modality,
and many of them are actually in a clinical trial.
But here, we aim to further
improve the therapeutic index and increase the efficacy
with the antibody drug conjugation approach.
Mechanistically, this heterobifunctional molecule will induce the
proximity between the E3 ligase and your protein of
interest,
and promotes the polyubiquitination of your target protein,
followed by proteasome-mediated
degradation. So basically, you hijack the
endogenous polyubiquitination, ubiquitin proteasome
machinery in the cells.
There are several advantages of using TPDs.
We can achieve excellent potencies.
We can discuss this in a few slides.
And also, a mechanism of action of this molecule is a
catalytic activity. It's an event-driven pharmacology,
unlike traditional small molecule with
occupancy-driven pharmacology.
And also, TPD can prolong the pharmacodynamics
effect, PD effect, resulting from the protein resynthesis.
Once you get rid of this protein in cancer cells, it takes some time
for cancer cells to recover the loss of protein.
And potentially, they enhance the pharmacological functions by
targeting, regulating your PPIs, protein-protein
interactions, or even disrupting the larger
protein complex by degrading one of the subunits of
the complex. So these are also very unique
to the targeted protein degrader modality.
So overall, TPDHas a really
promising
approach
by using as a payload molecule.
So here we are looking at the classes of
payload of ADCs that are approved
or in clinical trials. As you can see, a majority
of ADCs use three cytotoxic payload classes,
microtubule inhibitors, topoisomerase inhibitors, and
DNA-damaging agent.
So we think the TPDs uniquely could serve as a
payload with excellent potency and additional
benefits that I just discussed in the previous slides.
So here is a summary of advantages and their rationale
by using TPD as a payload.
We can achieve exceptional potency,
enabling the possibility of lower DAR ADCs
and improve the developability. We can keep the
molecule permeabilities, so that allows
bystander effect, especially in the context of solid tumors.
And we can design the TPD to have a high clearance,
which may reduce the systemic toxicity.
We can also design it as a prodrug, which also
may reduce the systemic toxicity and improve the
developability.
The highly stable linker is also
very important factors for the TPD molecules.
So I'm coming back to this in a few minutes.
And again, typically, TPDs are
non-genotoxic, so it's good for developabilities and
also are suitable for therapeutics beyond cancer
with the longer-term treatment.
So here I'm showing how we actually optimized
TPD payload as well as the payload linker.
As you can see, there are many places that we wanted to
optimize.
We had a really extensive medicinal chemistry
campaign combined with biology screening.
Because MMAE and the topoisomerase I inhibitor already have
exceptional anti-cancer
potency, we are also really focused on getting
the exceptional degradation potency in picomolar range.
We also needed to keep the reasonable permeability
and metabolism, high clearance for the ideal
payload candidates, as well as the balanced
polarity and non-genotoxicity for the
reasonable drug developability.
In terms of the payload linker optimization,
we needed to test in the DAC format.
So we conjugated the designed payload linkers to
appropriate antibodies, and we tested this DAC
format in cellular assays to generate the SAR.
And we also looked at the stability and
aggregation state of these generated DACs to
really keep looking at the developability as well.
So with this constant feedback loops enabled
us to identify a series of really interesting
novel
TPD molecule, as well as the payload linker that
supports the efficacy of the TPD
payload.
So now I'm going to talk about our first target.
We are looking at the SMARCA2 and SMARCA4.
These are the ATPase catalytic subunit
of the SWI/SNF complex. This complex is a
major chromatin remodeling complex.
This SWI/SNF complex contained either SMARCA2
or SMARCA4 in the cells.
Dual inhibition of the SMARCA2 and SMARCA4 have been
shown to
inhibit certain cancer types,
such as prostate cancer and hematological cancers such
as AML. However, this simultaneous inhibition or
targeting degradation of SMARCA2 and
has been also associated with limited, really challenging
tolerability issues. So we thought that
antibody drug conjugation with SMARCA2/4 dual
degradation could represent a really promising
approach for a new therapeutic modality.
We identified a novel SMARCA2/4 bromodomain
binder from fragment screening and
the
structure-based drug design approach.
This tricycle with the phenol,
this SMARCA2/4 binder with the VHL
ligand, we generated this Degrader 02.
And in high bit cell screening, we saw the SMARCA2
degradation potency was about 300 nanomolar.
And we optimized this starting point of
SMARCA2/4 dual degrader, and we identified the Degrader
04,
which significantly improved the degradation
potency that I'm going to show you in the following slides.
But we first wanted to validate this
degrader for in broad cell line panel to
identifyThis
more sensitive cancer types to SWI/SNF
inhibition. As you can see here in the cell line panel data,
there are notably sensitive cancer types such
as prostate cancer, breast cancer, TNBC, ER
positive HER2 breast cancer, and also the lymphoma,
AML, and multiple myeloma.
And also, there are subsets of
solid tumors in the middle,
show the reasonable
response. So it might be interesting to see if we can find
a biomarker-driven approach in these indications.
We did see comparable anti-proliferation
activity between the MMAE and Degrader-IV
in prostate cancer cell lines.
We tested this Degrader-04 in vivo models,
VCaP and then LNCaP. These are prostate cancer CDX
models. As you can see, the Degrader-04 show the
dose-dependent, a really strong anti-tumor activity.
However, as you can imagine, this payload, the dual degrader,
had a time and dose-dependent toxicity.
Mouse body weight loss and animal deaths were observed,
highlighting the poor tolerability of this molecule.
This is something we expected. So again, the ADC approach
was wanted.
So we validated this new concept, the SMARC2 for DAC
in various
clinically validated antigen targets such as
PSMA, CalR, Trop-2,
NCD123, CCND5, and MET, and the list goes
on. So we conjugated these
clinically validated antibodies with SMARC2 for dual degraders
to generate the SMARC2 for DAC or precision DAC.
We tested these DACs in different cancer cell lines, and we
confirmed the antigen-selective activities in vitro.
So I'm going to show you some of the data from the PSMA and
mutant CalR validation programs today.
But just a little bit of
details in the structure. This is the
Degrader-04 structure, VHL-based SMARC2 for
degrader.
The potency of degradation of SMARC2 was
370 picomolar now, so it's about
1,000-fold better than Degrader-02.
SMARC4 degradation potency was about 2.7 nanomolar.
And we used this NH as a linkage site.
We generated the payload Linker-01.
Now you can see here in the proteasome,
cleavable val-Ser dipeptide.
And using this Payload-01, we generated
the DAC-02 with J591.
It is anti-PSMA monoclonal antibodies.
And this DAC-02 showed
dose-dependent internalization signals in
LNCaP PSMA-positive cells, but not the PSMA-negative
PC3 cells. We also confirmed the SMARC4
degradation in antigen positive,
PSMA positive LNCaP cells, but not PSMA-negative
PC3 cells.
And we tested this DAC in vivo models.
So you can see here in the LNCaP model,
DAC-02 weekly dosing showed robust anti-tumor
activity, but not in the PSMA-negative
PC3 CDX models. But more importantly,
we did not see the significant body weight loss or
mouse deaths in these models, highlighting the improved
therapeutic index compared to the degrader payload
itself.
But we weren't so happy with this degradation potency.
As you can see, the SMARC4 degradation potency was
at 2.7 nanomolar. Like
I said earlier, we really wanted to have a better potency,
picomolar range potency. So we spent some time on
improving this degradation potency, and we even switched the
E3 ligase from VHL ligand to cereblon ligand, and
we identified the Degrader-06, which
had 40 and 90 picomolar degradation potency for
SMARC2 and SMARC4 respectively. We were also
able to reduce the fold selectivity between the SMARC2 and
SMARC4. Now it's only 2.3, so we are almost
equally degrade the SMARC2 and SMARC4 in the cells.
We are also able to maintain the high clearance
of this molecule to minimize the free payload exposure.
But this Degrader-06 had another problem.
This is the hydrolysis. This is well-known
inactivation of cereblon ligand part.
The ring opens up, and it becomes inactive.
So we looked at the stability of this Degrader-06 in human plasma
and mouse plasma, and half-life was only 34 hours.
This is less than one and a half days.
This is pretty short half-life as a payload.
And unfortunately, this could also happen on
antibody as well. We tested the similar studies,
human plasma incubation for two days of the DAC-09
and DAC-10, and we found that
74% and 81% of
conjugated this Degrader-06 was already
inactive.So in order to
advance the molecule to in vivo efficacy
study, weekly dosing efficacy, or even nominate the degrader antibody
conjugate candidate, we really needed to improve
this stability of TPD molecule. So
the medicinal chemistry approach could extend this
payload stability in plasma. Now you have
more than 200 hours. This is actually more than 10 days of half-life
of the degrader 07.
Even the potency was slightly better, and now selectivity is one
times 1x.
So we are pretty happy with this degrader 07 as a payload
candidate. We checked the selectivity of this
degrader in the global proteomics mass spec, and you can see
SMARCA2 and SMARCA4 on the top. And also, I
highlighted a couple of subunits of SWI/SNF complex
started to pop up in this graph,
indicating the disruption of SWI/SNF complex in
LNCAP cells.
So currently, we are using this degrader
07 bioconjugation to various antibodies for
proof of concept studies.
And in the next couple of slides, I'm going to show you early
stage of mutant Calr
SMARCA2/4 DAC validation studies.
Mutant Calr is frequently expressed in MPN
cells.
And
it alters C-terminus of the protein, and it binds
to MPL, the thrombopoietin receptor,
to induce the constitutively active JAK-STAT
signaling.
And only this mutant Calr can
bind to this MPL receptor and expose to the
extracellular matrix, you can selectively
target
mutant Calr-expressing cells, but not healthy
normal cells.
So we conjugated SMARCA2/4 degrader to the mutant
Calr antibodies, and then we tested in vitro
first. You can see here mutant, this Calr DAC,
show the SMARCA2 and four degradation only in Calr
mutant cells, but not in Calr wild-type cells.
We also confirmed the better anti-proliferation
activity of this Calr SMARCA2/4 DAC
in Calr mutant cells but compared to Calr
wild-type cells.
Now we tested this Calr SMARCA2/4 DAC in
vivo models, TF1 Calr Del52 frameshift
mutation expressing CDX models. As you can see
here in this model, the weekly dosing of this DAC showed robust
anti-tumor activity at really well-tolerated doses.
We confirmed the target engagement by looking at the reduction of
SMARCA2/4 protein level in the treated tumor as well,
which supports the in vivo mechanism of action.
So this is my last slide.
I hope I was able to convince that TPD, targeted
protein degraders, could represent the next
generation of payload
of ADCs. We can achieve exceptionally potent
and stable molecules with this TPD approach.
We validated this novel,
the modality with SMARCA2/4 degraders in various
different type of cancer types in
vitro to confirm the antigen-selective
activities. Also, in vivo efficacy confirmed
that improved therapeutic index.
Thank you very much.
Open to questions.
Hi, very nice talk. And I'm very curious about
the bystander killing effects of the DAC.
The other question is, you mentioned that the DAC is
events-driven. And what's the percentage of a
degradation you need to achieve to kill the tumor?
Sorry, I couldn't hear the first question.
The question is the bystander killing effects of the DAC.
Bystander killing, you know.
Bystander. Yeah.
It's depending on the molecule,
but we do see the bystander effect in vitro
studies.
Very nice talk.
How big is your molecule? Because ADCs are
about 150 kilodaltons, and they penetrate tumors
very poorly. I would imagine that this is bigger than that.
Sorry, I couldn't really...
So the audio is actually pretty bad in this room. Can you repeat the question?
I think the question is how good-
How big.
How big? Okay.
How big
of the TPD molecule?
Of the entire drug conjugate, the TPD, yeah.
Again, it's depending on the TPD molecules and the
linker.
But
we did not see
lots of aggregation in the product, so we could-
What I'm concerned about is tumor penetration, because
ADCs are 150 kilodaltons, and they
penetrate tumors very poorly.
Mm-hmm.
So I'm wondering, by adding this, how big are you making?
As you saw the structure, we discussed a couple of structures.
The molecule itself is not so large compared
to the other molecules like
MMAE and topoisomerase inhibitors.
So
I think we believe that it is not the concern for
us.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the great talk.
So I have two questions regarding the TPD molecule
that you have used and also the DACs.
So you mentioned about the
ring open stability and the plasma stability regarding the
CRBM-based degraders for utilizing
as a degrader antibody conjugate payload.
I wonder how much extent you can
actually extrapolate the plasma
stability of the degrader itself to
the actual stability inside
the DACs when you actually make the ADC
molecule. That's the first question.
Yeah.
And then the second question is you mentioned
about around the double-digit picomolar
DC50 values for the
payload you have used. Do you believe that's sort of the
boundary range for the DAC payloads
to achieve, or is it depending on the
target that you are dealing with?
Yeah, those are both really great questions.
The stability
question,
we just found out about this, and I think we need to
really do a lot of studies to find out
the
ring opening rate in the ADCs. That's
something we really would like to perform.
And then is this depending on the molecules and
antibody as well? We are actually surprised that we didn't see this much of
hydrolysis on the antibodies. So this is something we
tried to do a lot, but a med chem
approach could really improve that by
modulating the
cell ligand part.
And the second question, the picomolar range.
Yes, like you said, I think it's depending on the
cancer types and again, the molecule as well.
And it's also the balance between the potency and the
DAR. We tested a couple of different DARs, but again, we
do see sometimes increase, but sometimes that doesn't really increase
the potency. So it's really depending on
the cancer types and sensitivity to the SMIG2 for
targeting.
We're probably going to take the final question here.
Sure. Coming back to the previous question on the H50.
First of all, thank you very much. Very nice talk on the next-gen payload.
I'm wondering within the cell line that you have tested, I mean, different
indication, could you find any correlation between
why you have sensitivity in certain
subtypes or certain indications or not?
And secondly, I saw the data on the Linkab.
I know it's a very resilient model.
And you tried the weekly dosing. However, I didn't
see reaching to a kind of a full regression.
Even after the day 20,
it looked like that the model is growing back.
So do you think you need some sort of a dose adjustment?
What I'm trying to get out of it is what we are looking in terms of the
efficacy with the PSMA perhaps in the patients.
Yes. The first question,
the biological mechanism of this inhibition of
SWI/SNF complex, there are
many publications out there.
I think overall,
like transcription and enhancer-addicted cancers, or
like hormone receptor-driven cancers are relatively sensitive.
As you saw, the prostate cancer and
ER-positive cancer are relatively more sensitive.
So I think that also play a role a lot, in terms of
the sensitive cancer types.
And the second question, the potency
of the degradation and in vivo
models,
yeah, it is hard to
say.
Yeah, that's something we are also
trying to do in different cancer types, to look
at the DACs with the different
potency as well.
Okay. I think we're going to wrap up this session.
I want to thank my fellow speakers and also thank you for participating.
Enjoy the rest of the day and also the conference. Thank you, guys.